I had this meeting with a big Studio
Hollywood casting director and he looked
at me and he said everybody knows you're
a beautiful talented black girl but what
do I do
with a beautiful talented black girl do
I put you in a movie
with Tom Cruise does he kiss you uh who
goes to see that movie he hurt me so
deeply I was actually thinking about
quitting until
I started to think he said that
everybody knew that I was a beautiful
talented black girl
so what was meant to break me did not
break me it built me up and I walked out
of there giving myself permission to
take up space in Hollywood knowing that
I belong there no matter what anybody
thought about me
[Applause]